I think our women's program got started
a lot sooner and with a lot more
seriousness than the rest of the world.
I think most,
most of the rest of the world doesn't
respect women's soccer.
Whereas here we're like,
that's great.
You know,
that's awesome.
And so we're gonna put the money and
resources into it to make them the best
team that they can be.
And I think we got a good jump on the
rest of the world in that fashion
because,
uh,
the rest of the world was like women's
soccer,
you know,
I mean,
who's ever.
It's all about men's soccer everywhere
and that's all everybody cares about.
So even now,
even though they have women's national
teams in place,
there's still not that respect that we
give our women's national team here,
uh,
which is,
you know,
disappointing on a lot of levels for the
rest of the world.
But for here we give our women's
national team the same kind of coverage
would give them meds.
We give them the same respect.
I'm they have some great players and
it's cleared out the countries that have
started taking it a little more serious
in the women's game are starting to be
at our women's team and so,
you know,
there's seems to be,
like five or six top teams that uh,
the US included that are,
uh,
you know,
kind of just,
there's the,
is being switched back and forth now and
we don't,
us doesn't dominate as much.
Now there's some trepidation in the US
soccer camp that,
you know,
we might have lost our foothold and uh,
the women's soccer a spectrum.
So that's good.
It's good.
Only good for our program.
I'm glad to have some fear because they
were running the show for,
for a number of years.
Absolutely.
I think,
uh,
just a touch about the competition
angle.
I think once the other teams will say,
Germany,
Germany's got a very good women's
national team.
Once they kind of decided,
you know,
what,
we want our German team to win.
We don't want USA to win everything.
Then they started being like,
then the competition comes in and the
pride comes in.
And so now they've got a great women's
national team and it competes with our
team in Brazil as well.
Uh,
just another country that it does some
of the same.
So,
uh,
I hope that would,
that would generate more respect for the
women's game.
Uh,
I don't see why it wouldn't,
but,
you know,
that being said,
it could just be a pride thing and I
don't want to lose the United States.
And I mean ultimately it's a good thing
all the way around,
just means more exposure for the women's
game.
Uh,
I have a 10 month old daughter at home
named Julia.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
I have a much different appreciation for
women's sports and I probably would have
otherwise because,
you know,
I want her to at least have that as an
option if that's something she wanted
to.